in our morning rounds new research
suggests women's brains do not age as
fast as men's studying the Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences
analyzed brain scans of more than 200
notes from age 20 to 82 female brains
appeared on average almost four years
younger metabolically than male brains
of the same age researchers at the
Washington University School of Medicine
measured the flow of oxygen and glucose
now that's a type of sugar known to
change as we grow older doctor Gayatri
Devi is a neurologist at Lenox Hill
Hospital part of the Norwell health who
specializes in memory disorders and good
morning so this is interesting what have
we learned about why women's brains are
younger we actually don't really know we
can speculate that it's because the
genes that are responsible for energy
metabolism in women stay active longer
don't change as fast as they do in men
but it was a great study because they
looked at over 200 brains of men and
women ages 20 to 80 and they found
throughout lifespan that women on
average their brains were using energy
at about four years younger
the computers estimated that their
brains were four years does that mean
that women are intellectually superior -
well it's not about yourself for someone
with a drowsy brain let me ask you this
question what does it mean to be
metabolically younger for people who may
not know what the word metabolically
means does that means that you are
behaving your brains are behaving and
using energy as a brain four years
younger than what the computer estimates
the brain based on the first question I
had it's really good the first question
I got then why is it that more women
develop Alzheimer's than men if they're
functioning metabolically better yeah so
we're not really sure why it could be
that you know that hormones may have a
role to play it could also mean that
women we do know that women who have
cardiovascular problems live longer than
men with cardiovascular problems and
cardiovascular problems are one of the
risks for Alzheimer's disease but there
are multiple multiple reasons why that
could be and there's no cure yet for
Alzheimer's
but nervously we can do and and I want
to ask you about that because well dudes
diet and exercise play oh a big role so
about fifty to sixty percent of cases of
Alzheimer's can be prevented by simple
lifestyle changes you could actually
very simple things you can exercise
aerobic exercise thirty to forty minutes
three to four times a week actually
helps to grow brain cells and increases
blood flow to the brain right any kind
of diet that's good for you primarily
people ask me what kind of diet any diet
that's good for the heart is good for
the brain
so a Mediterranean diet is a fun good
way to eat healthy is there anything
that men can do to catch up to our
brains I doubt it spend more time in the
company of that's always a good thing to
do I'm half kidding but is there
anything people can do really - yeah so
outside so you can actually people think
what can I do exercises and puzzles
Sudoku etc I think if you are somebody
who doesn't get frustrated by Sudoku or
crossword puzzle to do them but if they
frustrate you do anything that makes you
happy learn to do
I don't know salsa dance take up
sculpture take up anything that makes
you really excited and fun and engages
you in life and the other great secret
good brain health mm-hmm it's easy it
was funny please yes yes sleep is the
easiest best thing you could do we're
gonna say sex doctor Gayatri Devi I'm
grabbing the steering wheel back to the
straight road thank you so to do list